so it's been a little while since we've
looked at logs so I think it would help
all of us if we've got our heads back
into gear and at the same time did sort
of thinking that would help us work out
what does this look like that's not
graph means graphic as it's a visual
thing so we usually when we're trying to
work out what a what a graph looks like
if we have no idea though clue then we
start to try out some values and we draw
a table just so that we can gather our
values in a nicely way okay so here's
what we're going to do here now we've
normally don't write this down because
that's rub it out in a second we've
normally chosen values whoops
I need my blackboard again we've
normally chosen values for X or Y so
that we can get a rough idea like across
the whole Cartesian plane it's just
going to look accurate so for example
again don't write this we might have
tried out now use like this we've done
this in the past do you remember every
time we had a look at say the parabola
the cubic curve these are the values
that we checked out because this is
right in the middle the Cartesian plane
this is a bit to the left this is a bit
to the right and that was enough to get
a pattern remember that we've done this
quite a few times
however I know a few things about this
graph in advance that will tell us that
actually this is not a very helpful set
of values to choose you can actually do
these you just won't get as much helpful
information as you need
so the actual values I want you to write
down are the very first one we're going
to make it negative one the second one's
going to be zero the next one's going to
be one you like so far it's still very
very civil up it's going to be civil for
the next one too but then here's where
it's going to change four and eight okay
even a broken clock is Right twice a day
okay now he didn't catch that I was yet
never bowed doesn't pay enough attention
oh now what yeah but you won't hear him
and it doesn't so here's all you to do
we're going to test some values out and
then once we've got the values we load
the points that this graph goes through
and then we can draw ourselves a plane
okay so let's think about this I'm going
to start an unusual spot I'm going to
start here okay now this is an x value
I'm going to use this x value to work
out a y value so I'm going to test when
X is equal to 1 y is going to be equal
to log how do I read this again to
remember what words I actually say log
base 2 of 1 with X which is 1 in this
case so log base 2 of 1 so it's been a
little while since we looked at log so
maybe can't quite remember what this
means is there's a number that you can
raise to to that power and it will give
you 1 2 to the power something gives you
1 2 to the power of 1 gives you 1 the
answer is 0 because actually anything to
the power of 0 will give you 1 okay so
therefore I can say when X is equal to 1
Y is equal to 0 let's keep on going and
you'll see fairly rapidly why I've
chosen these particular values of X
which receive a bit random at first when
X equal to 2 y will be log base 2 of 2
because my x value is changing you see
that log base 2 of 2 now remember what
this means it means to the power of
something gives me 2 well what's for
something so what to the power of 1 is 2
so this is 1 you see that so 2 to the
power of 1 gives you 2 this is this
weird sort of backwards way that logs of
read okay
we'll do one more then you can do the
last one you can tell me the last one
without it even writing it let's test
out x equals four okay so let's get to
it let's get to it if X is equal to four
then Y is log base 2 of 4 so 2 to the
power of something gives you 4 and
you've already worked out the pattern 2
squared is 4 so that's a 2 so now can
you tell me what this is 2 to the power
of something gives you 8
well it's 3 isn't it 2 cubed is 8 ok so
now you can see why I chose these
numbers they were not out random ok now
let's look at what's happening over here
cuz this is not what you expect what's
this one let's test X equal 0 ok so this
means if x is 0 Y is 3 to be equal log
base 2 of 0
now put your pen down for a moment what
does this mean 2 to the power of
something gives you 0 ^ 2 ^ now we've
already we already know what ^ 0 is 2 to
the power of 0 is 1 so 0 is not it
how about a negative number like 2 to
the power of negative 1 what would that
be that's 1/2 your calculator can help
you with this right 2 to the power of
1/2 what's that that's the square root
of 2 we're not getting 0 okay in fact
there's no number you can put it here
that makes this work ok yes so what
you've done is you've shown the
limitation of your calculator not found
the ATO okay ah yes we will come to this
exact point in a second so
ugly ordinarily at least if you do not
pay attention you've got other resources
you can have a look at afterwards when
you decide all to revise for my test
I'll have I'll have a read of this and
then that will prepare me this you've
got nothing so that's why I watch should
I pay attention did that make sense tell
you I'm not going to go everyone on you
ok so here we've got no value to yet no
solution
ok so up here I'm going to say I'm just
going to I'm just going to put an X I
got nothing I'm out ok now what about
this last one over here negative one so
what's log base two of negative one what
power can I raise 2 to to get negative
one you said negative zero megazor is
there if you try out negative one we
already tried this to the power of
negative one is a half that's what your
index laws all the way back then taught
you ok to the power of 1/2
you should find it's about 1.4 it's the
square root of 2 none of these numbers
are negative did you notice that none of
them in fact there's no power that you
can raise this to to get negative 1
there's no answers here
ok in fact no matter how far you go
you'll get no answers going all the way
to the left